let's say that someone's having a
conversation with an interlocutor and
it's getting a little bit heated or you
can't really get that other person to
communicate in an effective way what are
some of the strategies that people could
use to improve their Communication in
that situation to kind of de-escalate it
to bring it down and to start getting
everyone at the table again this is such
a big issue now because we seem to be
more intolerant one of the things that I
try to tell people is that distance
always helps angling away this is very
intense but if you angle away if you can
create some space even something as
subconscious as doing a artificial
cathartic exhale where you go
just doing that exhale let the other
person know at a subconscious level that
things need to calm down